Michael I've learned you since you were  a child you have a gift  you always have if there's an answer to  the disease we'll find it  [Music]  I should have died here as well  why am I still here if not to fix this  I have a rare blood disease and I'm  nothing at a time  this could be my last chance  [Music]  you're up to something what is it  that's not exactly label  I want to see you get hurt more than you  already have  this would be a cure  at what cost  [Music]  I went from time  [Music]  increased strength is speed  their ability is echolocation  and an overpowering urge to consume  blood  [Music]  how far are we allowed to go  we'll fix something that's broken  until the remedy  is worse than the disease  Michael Morbius attentive doing the old  good guy thing up what's up doc  you